[Music]  connor uh couldn't join us tonight you  know you guys are gonna go at each other  pretty soon people were talking about  this but he did come in he did send a  message and he sent a message and we're  gonna play it for you right now  what's up Conan sorry I couldn't make  the show this week but as a present to  you I sent Nate in my place  Nate I just hope he's not up on that  stage wearing that stupid black t-shirt  he's never out of the boys been wearing  that same time t-shirt for the past 20  years or something and I'm taking this  contest very very seriously I've flown  in specific body types to replicate  Nate's skinny tall frame the Boy Wonder  a lot of the last time he knows it I  know it well August 22 I get my revenge  and I look forward to it you got the  t-shirt on yeah  Connor is saying you won the lottery  last time you got lucky how do you  respond Jude came out and it's coming  truth will be August 20th when it goes  down again  [Applause]  you